hey dr. Berg here we're going to talk
about what's really behind liver spots
okay they're also called aging spots or
solar Lenti go it's not really the liver
now if the livers bad or dysfunctional
yes it can create all sorts of problems
with the skin but if you have actual
liver spots it's coming from the vitamin
C deficiency okay
vitamin C protects the skin from the Sun
okay it's called photo damage or damage
from the Sun or light so vitamin C
protects the skin from the Sun the skin
is collagen the epidermis is all
collagen and vitamin C is highly
involved in the formation of collagen
and if you look at some of the natural
creams out there they have serums for
the skin to get rid of aging spots what
are they they're vitamin C based they
work on the external though you really
got to work on the inside out like
consume the food high in vitamin C not
necessary just put on the surface of
skin because it's going to come back
next time you go to the Sun so as you
age and you have the accumulation of Sun
and you actually have a vitamin C
deficiency the combination of that gives
you these little brown spots so why why
are you vitamin C deficient as time goes
on it's either two reasons number one
you're you're not consuming enough
vitamin C and I'm not talking about
taking vitamin C as a supplement most
vitamin C supplements are synthetic
they're made from ascorbic acid and
they're made artificially from
cornstarch and sulfuric acid so
especially if it's over like 100
milligrams we know it's synthetic okay
it's artificial it's not going to fix it
vitamin C in nature is a complex of a
whole bunch of different parts and so
you want to get it from the food or our
concentrated food so vegetables collard
greens cabbage bell pepper chili pepper
parsley all those are very high in
vitamin C large salads high in vitamin C
pasteurization when they cook vegetables
if you heat them you destroy the vitamin
C so like orange juice for example has
like not a lot of vitamin C because it's
pasteurized so so that's one thing
all right now number two the probably
the more likely reason why you're
deficient vitamin C is not necessarily
you're not getting the vitamin C it's
because of a condition called insulin
resistance this is a lot of other videos
I have let insulin resistance of the
condition where your cells are blocking
insulin because of too much too many
carbs okay and then what happens or too
many frequent meals what happens it
sends a signal back to the pancreas and
it tells the body to make more insulin
so insulin resistance is a state where
you're producing a large quantity of
insulin which then depletes vitamin C
okay in the presence of too much insulin
you're not going to be able to absorb or
use vitamin C in the quantities you want
so you've got in the Sun you get this
aging spots liver spots of course not
the liver and that's what's causing it
so if you want to correct it
don't use the external serums fix it
from within and correct the insulin
resistance and consume enough vitamin C
I'll put some links down below how to do
that but that's really what's behind
liver spots thanks for watching hey you
probably already subscribed but if you
haven't press this little button down
below and I will keep you updated